[Música]
Estados Unidos no entrará en impago el
senado aprobó la ley de aumento del
techo de la deuda con 63 votos a favor y
36 en contra la legislación pasa ahora a
la firma del mandatario para hacer
promulgada y se logró tras arduas
negociaciones entre las partes ampliamos
desde Washington
nayib bukele cumplió 4 años como
presidente de El Salvador en su discurso
de rendición de cuentas defendió su
política contra el crimen organizado
anunció que presentará proyectos de ley
para reducir las alcaldías de 262 a 44 y
el número de congresistas de 84 a 60
la fiscal general de Ecuador Diana
Salazar denunció haber recibido amenazas
de muerte contra ella y su hija los
hechos se presentan en medio de un
recrudecimiento de la violencia en el
país con atentados contra jueces y
Fiscales en meses pasados Tenemos
reporte
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Estados Unidos porque el senado aprobó
con 63 votos a favor y 36 en contra la
ley de aumento del techo de la deuda que
ahora pasa al despacho Dual para que el
presidente la firme conectamos con
Cristóbal Vázquez corresponsal de France
24 en la capital estadounidense
Cristóbal Qué implicaciones tiene esta
aprobación del senado y que reacciones
se han producido
se necesitaban 60 votos en la cámara
alta en el senado y los demócratas solo
tenían una mayoría simple pero se hizo
este acuerdo bipartidista con los
republicanos moderados y los demócratas
se comprometieron a firmar un acuerdo y
un documento legal diciendo que en caso
de que se necesitara más dinero en
defensa pues se podría contemplar la
opción de aumentar el gasto en defensa
que era precisamente uno de las cosas
que más pedían los republicanos para
contar con los votos suficientes para
que se aprobara este proyecto en el
senado los votos entonces fueron 63 a
favor y 36 en contra y ahora pasa a que
el presidente Joe biden lo firme ya el
presidente ha reaccionado diciendo que
firmará este proyecto de ley lo más
pronto posible recordemos que levanta
este techo de la deuda y evita
financiero hasta el primero de enero del
2025 hasta esa fecha también el gobierno
de Joe Se comprometió a
respetar el límite de gasto público es
decir no podrá pasarse de un límite de
gasto público ya establecido en los
presupuestos que
se ha cuadrado entre los demócratas y
republicanos pero las reacciones pues
obviamente no se fueron fueron bastante
rápidas la primera de ellas de el líder
de El senado quien dijo que los
demócratas votaron más a favor de este
proyecto de ley precisamente porque
fueron los que más ganaron con este
acuerdo bipartidista y es que hay que
Resaltar que el voto moderado no el voto
de los extremos progresistas o radical
conservador de los republicanos fue el
que llevó adelante este proyecto para
que se firme este viernes el proyecto de
ley ya el presidente también anunció que
las siete de la noche de este viernes
será el discurso para pues promover y
para celebrar este acuerdo bipartidista
para evitar el deporte en Estados Unidos
Muchas gracias por esta ampliación
nosotros continuamos en Estados Unidos
Porque algunos estados republicanos como
Texas y Florida Siguen con sus esfuerzos
por dificultar el tránsito y estadía de
migrantes en situación legal y regular
sin embargo decenas de estos migrantes
en su mayoría de origen latino se están
organizando para manifestar su rechazo a
estas nuevas políticas por otro lado
estados como Chicago catalogados como
santuarios por su apertura recibir
migrantes expresan su descontento va
ante el bajo apoyo Federal a su causa el
informe es de Max Pérez Gallardo
Un día sin inmigrantes con ese nombre
decenas de trabajadores de origen latino
manifestaron su descontento en las
calles de Florida decidiendo suspender
sus labores un día para mostrar el valor
de su trabajo para la economía del país
su objetivo principal Mostrar su rechazo
a la nueva ley firmada por el gobernador
ronde santis que exige a los empleadores
utilizar un software especial que
delataría el estatus migratorio de las
personas y les impediría ser contratados
En caso de que sea irregular muy
importante comunidad porque hace los
trabajos que la mayoría no hacen so
nosotros trabajamos mucho en el país 15
16 horas seguidos sin parar sostenemos
mucho pagamos impuestos también como
todos en Texas otra demostración similar
tuvo como protagonistas a los dreamers
son hijos de inmigrantes en situación
irregular pero fueron traídos a Estados
Unidos desde niños los dreamers son
beneficiarios del programa daca creado
en la época de Obama que ha sido objeto
de una querella iniciada por el estado
Texano lo que podría provocar su
desaparición
estamos algo permanente no algo temporal
que tenemos que estar renovando cada dos
años por otro lado ciudad de santuario
como Chicago redoblan esfuerzos Para
apoyar a los migrantes el consejo de la
ciudad aprobó un paquete de ayuda por 51
millones de dólares con el objetivo de
mejorar las condiciones de los
solicitantes de asilo Aunque algunas
voces mencionan que no es suficiente
51 millones de dólares durarán unos
pocos tal vez dos meses y eso es solo
servicios eso no es la adquisición de
sitios es una estrategia a largo plazo
la crisis migratoria en Estados Unidos
es objeto de una lucha ideológica entre
republicanos y demócratas una batalla en
la que sólo pierden los migrantes
en El Salvador se cumplieron o cuatro
años del mandato del presidente nayib
bukele el jefe de estado presentó su
balance en un discurso ante la asamblea
legislativa y defendió su política de
seguridad asegurando que su país pasó de
Los Altos índices de violencia ser uno
de los más seguros en el mundo se estima
que al menos 69,000 personas han sido
detenidas como parte de la agresiva
estrategia del mandatario
en cuatro años
El Salvador es otro país eso no lo puede
negar nadie ni siquiera la oposición
ahora tenemos un nivel de seguridad de
que países de latinoamérica sueñan
no lo digo para jactarnos sino para que
cada uno lo analice y sea consciente de
lo que hemos logrado el país más pequeño
de América es ahora ejemplo para países
más grandes que cuentan con más recursos
porque los logros en seguridad son
irrefutables vamos a Chile donde este
jueves el presidente Gabriel borich
rindió su segunda Cuenta pública tras
quince meses en el cargo y en medio de
una baja popularidad en su discurso de
más de tres horas y media el más largo
de un mandatario desde que volvió la
democracia borich se centró en la
inseguridad en el país uno de los puntos
que más preocupan a los chilenos así
como el proyecto de nueva constitución
seguimos profundamente convencidos de la
necesidad de avanzar hacia un país que
ofrezca más libertades
que practique la solidaridad para cuidar
a los más necesitados y que a la vez que
promueve el crecimiento distribuye de
manera justa la riqueza que genera
que se relaciona de una manera
sustentable y respetuosa con la
naturaleza
que defiende las diversidades y enfrenta
con firmeza al homofobia
en Ecuador la fiscal general Diana
Salazar denunció amenazas contra su vida
y la de su hija a través de WhatsApp
esto en un contexto donde en meses
anteriores se ha registrado un aumento
en la violencia con atentados contra
jueces y Fiscales la funcionaria también
enfrenta un proceso por supuesto plagio
en su tesis Universitaria y asegura que
hay una campaña de persecución en su
contra Gustavo Ortega corresponsal de
France 24 nos amplió desde quito
el gobierno ecuatoriano dispuestos toda
la protección necesaria para la fiscal
general del estado Diana Salazar Es que
la titular de la fiscalía general del
estado ha recibido denuncias de muertes
a través de medios digitales un video
que circula en las redes sociales en el
que un grupo armado le indica tener
todas sus ubicaciones que tome las
decisiones adecuadas y advierten de
atentar contra su vida el presidente de
la república Guillermo lasso anunció que
no permitirá que grupos armados atenten
contra la seguridad de autoridades del
Estado la fiscalía general del estado
también emitió un comunicado donde
rechaza las intimidaciones por hacer su
trabajo de investigación y se asignan la
Policía Nacional para protegerla además
hizo un llamado a la comunidad
internacional a mantenerse vigilantes de
lo que ya ha calificado como intento por
tomarse la institución por la fuerza
Diana Salazar también enfrenta
investigaciones en su contra que
aseguran que la titular de la fiscalía
habría supuestamente plagiado su tesis
de grado afirmaciones que ella ha negado
en todo momento de comprobarse el
supuesto plagio de su tesis esto podría
significar la destitución de su cargo la
titular de la fiscalía declaró
recientemente que se trata de
interesados que intentan tomar el
control de la institución por la fuerza
y señaló directamente a expresidente y a
un ex vicepresidente de la República
como supuestos involucrados así llegamos
al final de este informativo gracias por
su sintonía
[Música]